يكشف عن عدم حصول مجموعته على الذخيره من
روسيا ويحذر من التراجع في بخم
وت حاله تسمم طالبات ايران تصل الى 80
مدرسه وناشطات يدعون الاحتجاجات بيوم
المراه العالميه
وزير الدفاع التايوانيه يدعو للتاهب تحسبا
لدخول مفاجئ للجيش الصيني لمناطق قرب
الجزيره
[موسيقى]
التطورات تتلاحق على جبهه بخموت فقط كشف
مؤسس فاجنر ان معظم الذخيره التي وعدت بها
موسكو لم تحصل عليها المجموعه حتى الان
وحضر مؤسس فاجنر من ان التراجع في بخموت
يعني انهيار الجبهه باكملها ويهدد مصالح
روسيا بالتزامن زار وزير الدفاع الروسيه
مدينه ماريوبولفي دونيات جنوب اوكرانيا
للاطلاع على جهود استعاده البنيه التحتيه
في دومباس
اذا اكد مؤسس مجموعه فاجنر الروسيه يفريني
بريكوجين ان قوته تشدد قبضتها الان على
مدينه وقال ان ضعف امدادات الذخيره قد
يؤدي الى انهيار الجبهه باكملها وان اجبار
قوات فاجنر على الانسحاب يهدد المصالح
الروسيه او اشاره الى عدم تسلم معظم
الذخيره التي وعدت بها موسكو
وفي تصريحات خاصه للعربيه المحايوري ساك
مستشار وزير الدفاع الاوكراني الى احتمال
انسحاب اوكرانيا من بخموت اذ اعتبر القاده
العسكريون انه لا يوجد اهميه استراتيجيه
وراء هذه المعركه
عمليه الاجلاء من بخموت اصبحت مستحيله
بسبب تواصل القصف كما قال رئيسنا من قبل
فان الجيش سيواصل دفاعا ضخمه كلما استطاع
ذلك لكن هذا لا يعني اننا سنواصل الدفاع
عنها اذا لم نرى ضروره عسكريه لاننا نكترث
لحياه جنودنا اننا لن ندافع عنها باي ثمن
نحن نقاوم في بخموت وهذا سمح لجيشنا
بالدفاع عن جبهات اخرى
وزير والدفاع الروسي سرقش فيه وزاره مدينه
ماريوبولفيدونيات جنوب اوكرانيا وقالت
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان الزيارات تهدف
الى الاطلاع على جهود استعاده البنيه
التحتيه في دومباس واضافت تفقد الوضع في
ماريوبل ومشروعات المياه وتاهيل المباني
السكنيه
قبل ذلك اعلن حاكم منطقه بيلو جرود
الروسيه المتاخمه لاوكرانيا اسقاط ثلاثه
صواريخ في منطقه نوفي اوسكول فجره اليوم
واشار الى ان بعض خطوط الكهرباء وواجهات
المباني تضررت قرب بلده اوسكول جراء
الحطام كما اصيب مدنيون بشظايا
وكشف رئيس اداره مدينه يا سينوفاتا في
دنياتك
شانكو كشف عن سقوط حوالي 50 قتيلا واصابه
اكثر من 170 شخصا من قصف الجيش الاوكراني
للمدينه خلال العام الماضي
اضاف ايضا ان القصف الاوكراني دمر اكثر من
2000 منزل في المدينه الا ان السلطات تجري
عمليات ترميم واصلاح مستمره على حد قوله
يتصاعد التوتر بين بولندا والمانيا بشان
تسليح اوكرانيا بدبابات ليو بورد وقطع
الغيار الخاصه بها حيث تتهم وارسو جارتها
برلين بالتقاعس في ارسال الدبابات الى
الجبهات الاوكرانيه
في الباحه الخلفيه لاوكرانيا يتصاعد توتر
قد يهدد جبهتها المشتعله مع روسيا بعدما
حققت تقدما ملحوظا في استعاده اراضيها
بدعم غربي التهديد ياتي بسبب الخلافات بين
المانيا وبولندا بشان تزويد كييف بالاسلحه
حيث تتهم وارسو برلين بالتقاعس في ارسال
الدبابات الى الاوكرانيين حتى وصل الامر
بوارسو للتهديد بارسال دبابات المانيه الى
جبهات دون موافقه برلين المانيا كانت اعطت
الضوء الاخضر بارسال عدد محدود من دبابات
اليوبارد لكن البولنديين يقولون ان
النموذج الاقدم الذي التزموا بارساله
سيكون محدود الاستخدام دون قطع غيار
المسؤوليه الرئيسيه تقع على عاتق المانيا
المنتج الرئيسي لتلك الدبابات
كنا نحط الجانب الالماني منذ فتره طويله
على الانضمام الى التحالف وليس فقط تسليم
الدبابات وقطع الغيار ايضا الخلاف بين
البلدين ليس جديدا اذ تحيي وارسو مطالبها
مرارا بالتعويض عما تكبدته منذ ايام
الاجتياح النازي لاراضيها تعويض تقول انه
يبلغ تريليونا وثلاثه مليارات دولار
المانيا اعتبرت نبره جارتها الحاده ليست
الا مسرحا سياسيا قبل الانتخابات المقبله
وستزول مع نهايه الانتخابات التي تكلف
الحزب الحاكمه قبضته في البلاد
اكدت المتحدثه باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الروسيه ماريا خروف استعداد بلادها للوفاء
بالتزاماتها في مبادره البحر الاسود لنقل
الحبوب حال التزام بقيه اطراف الاتفاقيه
بتعهداتهم زخروا فاوضحت ايضا ان اتفاقيه
نقل الحبوب ملزمه لكل الاطراف لا لطرف
واحد يقابله التلاعب والمكائد على حد
وصفها
يعقد اليوم مجلس محافظي الوكاله الدوليه
اجتماعا في فيينا لاجراء مناقشات حول
تعزيز انشطه الوكاله المتعلقه بالسلامه
النوويه والعلوم والتكنولوجيا والتطبيقات
وستشمل المباحثات ايضا وفقا للتوقعات
مراقبه المنشات النبويه في ايران والاشراف
على الانشطه النوويه في كوريا الشماليه
بالاضافه الى قضايا الامن والضمانات في
محطه الطاقه النوويه في الخدعه للسيطره
الروسيه
اكدت احصاءات وقناه ايران انترناشونال ان
80 مدرسه على الاقل تواجه ازمه تسمم بسبب
تعرض طالباتها لهجوم كيمياوي وسط اهمال
بعض مسؤولين المدارس لتقديم المساعدات
اللازمه للتلميذات ووفقا لهذه الاحصاءات
فان حالات التسمم شملت محافظه طهران
وخوزستان ولوريستان وخرسان الرضويه وفارس
وصفهان واردبيل وهميدان واذربيجان الشرقيه
والغربيه وفي السياق قالت رئيسه مركز
الصحه غرب الاهواز انه ظهرت على تلميذات
اعراض مثل احمرار الوجه والبشره وضيق
التنفس من جهته اشار نائب رئيس جامعه
الاحواز للعلوم الطبيه الارتفاع حصيله
المتسممات في مدرسه خيام حيث تسممت 40
تلميذ على الاقل 10 منهن تم السماح لهن
بمغادره المستشفى
تبكي الامهات في ايران على عتبات مدارس
بناتهن العالقات في صفوف الدراسه
ويصرخن لاخراجهن قبل اختناقهن بهواء مسموم
بمواد ما تزال مجهوله لكنها على حد وصف
الفتيات كريهه وتشبه رائحه فاكهه متعفنه
ومن خرجت منهن فتبدو عليهن حاله اعياء غير
مفسره والحافلات تشارك سيارات الاسعاف في
نقلهن الى المستشفيات 50 مدرسه على الاقل
تواجه ازمه تسمم باعتراف وزير الداخليه
احمد وحيدي موضحا ان صحه الطالبات تمثل
الاولويه القصوى لجميع المسؤولين ليؤكد ان
المحققين استعادوا عينات مشبوهه مكتفيا
بهاتين الكلمتين دون اي تفاصيل اخرى ليضيف
اليهما دعوه الى الهدوء متهما للعدو
بالارهاب الاعلامي هجمه كيماويه هكذا تسم
العوائل البنات التي يلفظن سما جثا على
صدورهن يتمددن على اسره المستشفيات وكل
منهن تعاني توعكا ما بين غثيان ووهن ودوار
وسعال وضيق في التنفس
420 ناشطا سياسيا ومدنيا وصفوا في بيان
مشترك عمليه التصميم بالعمل الاجرامي ونقل
اعلام المعارضه الايراني عن المتخصص الطبي
محمد رضا هاشميان ان الاشخاص العاديين لا
يمكنهم الوصول الى الغازات التي تم
استخدامها لتصميم الطلاب
اما شيرين عبادي احدى الشخصيات البارزه
المعارضه للنظام فقالت انه اذا كان هناك
اي شك حول دور النظام في مسلسل تسميم
الطالبات فقد زال هذا الشك اليوم
اعتقلت السلطات الامنيه الايرانيه في
محافظه قم وسط ايران رئيس التحرير موقع قم
نيوز الاخباريه الصحفيه علي بورطبطبائي
بعدما كشف للمره الاولى عن حالات تسميم
الطالبات في المحافظه بحسب ما نشر موقع
اعتماد اون لاين الاصلاحي وذلك بعد نشر
طبطبائي الذي ينشط في تويتر باسم خيزران
تقارير حول هذه الظاهره التي بدات في
الثلاثين من نوفمبر
ومتابعتها بعد انتشار حالات جديده لا سيما
في المكان الاول الذي ظهرت فيه واعتبرت
صحف المعارضه ان اعتقال الصحفيين يعد
بمثابه ضغوط على الاعلام لعدم كشف حقيقه
الازمه
[موسيقى]
وضعت مجموعه من الناشطات الايرانيه الى
التظاهر في الشوارع في يوم المراه العالمي
الذي يصادف الثامن من مارس وذلك للاحتجاج
على ما وصف بالهجمات الكيمياويه على مدارس
التلميذات في ايراننا جاء في الدعوه التي
وقعها عدد من الناشطات في ايران وطالب
الجميع لا سيما الناشطين والناشطات
والعمال والطلاب الانضمام الى هذا
الاحتجاج والدفاع عن الاطفال وحقوق
الفتيات والنساء
وكان الرئيس الايراني ابراهيم رئيسي وصف
تسمم طالبات المدارس في بلاده وصفها
بالمؤامره ممن سماه بالعدو واعتبر رئيس
ايران خلال اجتماع حكومي ان تصميم
الطالبات حلقه اخرى ممن وصفه بالعدو
لاثاره التوتر والتهويل داخل المجتمع ونشر
الخوف على حد تعبيره
نشرتنا مستمره فيها بعض الفاصل
السلطات الموريتانيه تتعقب عناصر خطيره من
تنظيم القاعده بعد فرارهم من سجن وسط
واكشوط
اهلا بكم من جديد تطارد السلطات
الموريتانيه سجناء من مقاتلي تنظيم
القاعده بعد ان فروا من سجن وسط وعكشوط
كانوا ادينوا قبل عشر سنوات بالتورط فيها
هجمات ارهابيه ويوصف عناصر القاعده
الفارونه بالخاطرين جدا اذكر ان اثنين من
السجناء الهاربين شاركوا في هجمات على
ثكنات للجيش الموريتاني خلال فتره الارهاب
والمواجهه مع التنظيم ما بين عامي او
اعوام 2005 و2011
دعا وزير الدفاع التايوانيه تشيو كوتشانغ
الى التاهب تحسبا لاي دخول مفاجئ للجيش
الصيني في مناطق قريبه من الاراضي
التايوانيه وسط تصاعد التوترات العسكريه
عبر مضيق تايوان وزير الدفاع اوضح ايضا ان
الصين قد توجد اعذارا مختلفه لدخولها الى
المناطق القريبه من المجال الجوي والبحري
الاقليمي لتايوان
ياتي ذلك بينما اعلنت الحكومه الصينيه ان
الجيش سيزيد مخصصاته لاهداف دفاعيه المزيد
عن الميزانيه الضخمه في هذا التقرير
الصين في محاوله لمواجهه تحديات من ملف
تايوان الى الوجود العسكري الامريكي قرب
حدودها قررت رفع ميزانيتها العسكريه
لحوالي 224 مليار دولار ارقام تترجم توجها
صينيا جديدا تقول بكين انه يهدف لتعزيز
دفاعاتها القتاليه على مستوى العتاد
البشري بكين خفضت اعداد الجنود بشكل حاد
خلال العقد الماضي في اطار حمله تحديث
واطفاء طابع احترافي وتحسين الانفاق يضم
الجيش حاليا مليونين وخمسه مجند بين قوات
بريه وبحريه وجويه على مستوى العتاد
النووي تمتلك الصين حوالي 350 راسا نوويا
وسط اتهامات امريكيه سابقه بنيتها زياده
ترسانتها النوويه الى 1500 راس بحلول عام
على مستوى الاعداد الجوي تمتلك الصين
ثلاثه حاملات طائرات تعمل اثنتان منها فقط
حاليا والثالثه في مرحله اختبار في البحر
لكنها تصطدم بعراقيل لوجسيه وتقنيه معقده
اهمها تدريب العديد من الطيارين لجانب
محاولات حديثه لتطوير سلاحها الجوي باسطول
مقاتلات حربيه
على مستوى العتاد البحري تفاخر الصين
بانها اول قوه بحريه في العالم من حيث عدد
السفن لكن اسطولها يعتمد في الغالب على
فئات سفن اصغر على مستوى القواعد الخارجيه
لدى الصين قاعده عسكريه واحده فقط في
الخارج في جيبوتي تقول انها مخصصه بشكل
اساسي لعمليات مكافحه القرصنه رغم ما
تستعرضه الصين من عتاد عسكري الا انها لا
تزال متاخره في المنافسه مع الدول الغربيه
خاصه الولايات المتحده التي تفوقها عسكريا
بمراحل
وهو ما قد يضع هدف بكين على مسافه متاخره
جدا فيما يتعلق بالدفاع عن السياده او
اعاقه تدخل الولايات المتحده في المنطقه
يجري خفر السواحل اليابانيه عمليات البحث
عن سبعه اشخاص مفقودين بعد انقلاب قاربهم
الذي شهد اخر مره ينجرف قرب جزيره سينكاكو
في بحر الصين الشرقي المتنازعه عليها بين
طوكيو
اعلنت الخارجيه الامريكيه ترحيبها
بالقرارات التاريخيه الصادره عن حكومتي
كوريا الجنوبيه واليابان بشان اختتام
مناقشاتهما حول القضايا التاريخيه الحساسه
في تغريده لوزير الخارجيه الامريكي انطوني
بلينكن واشار بلينكن ايضا الى ان جمهوريه
كوريا الجنوبيه واليابان هما من اهم حلفاء
الولايات المتحده
[موسيقى]
قلم متحدث باسم الشرطه الباكستانيه ان
تفجيرا انتحاريا استهدف حافله لنقل الجنود
اسفر عن مقتل تسعه من افراد الشرطه في
اقليم بلوشستان بجنوب غرب البلاد اضف
المتحدث ان 15 فردا اخرين من الشرطه
اصيبوا في هذا الهجوم
الشرطه الباكستانيه مذكرات توقيف الى رئيس
الوزراء السابق عمران خان لضمان مثوله
امام المحكمه كما وجهت وكاله التحقيقات
الفيدراليه هامات ضده في محكمه مكافحه
الفساد التي اصدرت الاسبوع الماضي اوامر
اعتقال بعد ان فشل خان في المثول امام
المحكمه على الرغم من الاستدعاءات
المتكرره وفي اشاره الى غيابه عن المحكمه
قال خان ان المحاكم لم توفر الامن الكافي
لا يوجد امن في المحاكم انهم يعلمون اني
تلقيت تهديدا لحياتي يستدعونني في قضايا
صغيره للغايه من محكمه الى اخرى
اظهرت لقطات كاميرات المراقبه والتي نشرت
مؤخرا لحظه انهيار مبنى سكني في زلزال قوي
في ملاطيا التركيه في السادس من فبراير
الماضي حيث تسببت قوه الزلزال في تفكك
المبنى المكون من سبعه طوابق ما اسفر عن
مقتل 29 شخصا وفق وفقا لمسؤولين حكوميين
[موسيقى]
مختصون اتراك من حدوث تغير ديموغرافي كبير
في البلاد بسبب موجات النصوح لعشرات
الالاف من ضحايا الزلزال وفيما يفضل البعض
الفرار من الولايات الجنوبيه المتضرره نحو
مدن وسط وشمال تركيا شهدت كثير من القرى
كذلك هجره عكسيه للباحثين عن الامان
هذه المشاهد تتكرر يوميا خلال اولى ساعات
الصباحات انطاكيا المنكوبه فرار جماعي
للناجين من الزلزال الذي جعلها تاي من
اكبر المدن تضررا منهم من يملك وجهه محدده
ومنهم من سيحددها لاحقا خلال ساعات الرحله
الطويله بحثا عن الامان يعني على طلاق غصب
عني
دكاني هون
رفقاتي منهم ماتوا منهم راحوا لله الامر
بس
[موسيقى]
كل جيران في هذه البنايه والحي غادروا الى
مدن اخرى انا كذلك تقرر هدم بيت المتصدع
وساذهب الى انقره واعيش هناك عند اقاربه
كما السوريين الذين الفوا الترحاله دخل
الاتراك كذلك في هجره داخليه الى مدن
الشمال وعكسيه اعادت المئات منهم الى
القرى هنا بقريه جولباش بضواحيها تاي
ياملون النجاه بانفسهم من الزلزال وهزاته
المتتاليه لكن هذه السيده لا تامن الوضع
وتفضل الخيمه على البقاء داخل بيتها
منذ حدوث زلزال عدنا الى قرانه التي اصبحت
مزدحمه هي الاخرى هنا الوضع اقل خطوره من
مركز هاتاي لكني اخاف البقاء في البيت
لذلك انا في الخيمه
اما هذا الرجل فوجد نفسه لاجئا في خيمه
حتى وهو يعود الى قريته التي غادرها قبل
خمسه عقود من الاربعه وسبعين لها اليوم
هذا من القريه بعيد
رجعنا على مكان الاول باركين بالخيام مع
الندور ما عندنا شيء
وفقا للارقام الرسميه فقد عاد اكثر من
اربعين الف سوري طواعيه الى سوريا فيما لم
يتم الكشف بعد عن اعداد المنكوبين من
الاتراك وغيرهم ممن نزحوا مدن تركيه اخرى
تطمينات السلطات التركيه عده اعمار
المناطق المتضرره سريعا لم توقف موجات
النزوح الى عشرات الالاف من المنكوبين ما
يؤشر الى حدوث تغير ديموغرافي قد يزيد من
متاعب الحكومه في معالجه اثار الزلزال عبد
القادر خربوش العربيه
مؤسسوا فاجنر يكشف عن عدم حصول مجموعته
على ذخيره من روسيا ويحذر من التراجع في
بخموت
حالات تسمم طالبات ايران يصل لثمانين
مدرسه
ونشطات يدعون الاحتجاجات بيوم المراه
العالميه
وزير الدفاع التايواني يدعو للتاهب تحسما
لدخول مفاجئ للجيش الصيني لمناطق قرب
الجزيره
اراكم على راس الساعه على اللقاء
[موسيقى]